Let's go next to our caller from the five
oh six area code.
Who's calling today from five oh six.
Hello? Uh, I'm Thomas from Canada.
Hey Thomas.
What's going on?
Um, I'm a little concerned and I guess there's
an open ended question, but I'm a little concerned
with, uh, the stuff I've been reading about
Yang sort of take on climate and the climate
crisis.
So there's been like a number of articles
that say Andrew Yang is not your climate friend.
Uh, Andrew Yag report on climate in the debate
wasn't like super, well Wa wasn't super well
versed or whatever.
Okay.
Um, and I was just wondering like sort of
your take on that.
Um, he seemed a little, uh, pessimistic about
the issue and not, um, saying things like
we're 10 years too late, et cetera.
And generally the, the issue I think previously
has been like, we can't get politicians on
board with climate change and then Yang, the
sort of issue that people are thinking with
Yang and he's on board but he's a little too
pessimistic about it or that is his,
well, we'll talk about it
super dystopian.
I, uh, I actually appreciate, I mean, okay,
listen, there are candidates who just deny
the science and are completely disconnected
from reality and say everything's fine.
That's not good.
There are candidates who understand the crisis
but seem to think that we're like five years
away from solving everything if you only elect
them, which is not realistic to me.
So in a sense I find refreshing his sort of
dystopian pessimistic look, uh, assuming that
he doesn't get over to, there's just not even
a point in dealing with this because there's
no fixing it.
That would be a problem.
Right.
But I actually appreciate that he's being
a little more frank.
I mean the imagery he used during the second
debate on CNN where he said, we've got to
start talking to people about getting to higher
ground because there are coastal areas that
are going to be implying literally underwater
pretty soon.
I thought that that was actually really great
that he was using language that communicated
the urgency and and sort of crisis that we're
in.
I think the, the criticisms might be does
he have the right plan to deal with it and
if maybe your argument is like you feel he's
so pessimistic that he's not even focusing
enough on climate.
Is that what I'm hearing?
Well that's, that's the narrative that I sort
of saw in the media.
Yeah.
But as far as my personal take on what he
said, like had I not seen any other opinions
on it, if I just watched like his debate,
I was like, I was completely on board with
you and him sort of being like, yeah, there's
an extent of us that's just sort of screwed,
but let's take the action that we can do and
like higher ground, etc.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, I haven't read the piece you're
talking about, I should look at the piece
you're talking about and see what it argues.
But in my, in my study of Andrew Yang and
in my conversations that I've had with them,
I think I've had him on three or four times.
I've not been alarmed by his, his view on
climate.
I think, you know, the biggest criticism of
Andrew Yang's view on climate and other issues
would be he may see it too much like a consulting
project, right?
The sort of consulting ization of politics
is something that may be Andrew Yang as someone
whose background is entrepreneurship online
tech startups and whatnot.
Maybe that would be a fair critique.
Like the, the climate issue is, is a cultural
issue.
It's a scientific issue.
It's many more things than just like, let's
get the right consultants to solve the problem.
Um, that, but, but even that, I'm sort of
like steel manning the strongest argument
against him.
Yeah, no, like I'm a, I'm a huge fan of him.
And I was just wondering, sort of like how,
uh, if you had any criticism to the criticism
that he sort of took for that climate thing
and, um, we're all on the same page.
Yeah.
I mean, my reaction to what he said was the
same as what you said.
Uh, but I should read the critique you're
talking about and maybe it does have some
merit.
Yes, sure.
Yeah.
Alright.
Uh, Thomas from Canada.
Thank you.
Where in Canada are you calling from?
A Nova Scotia.
Oh, I've never been there, but I've got some
friends.
Uh, I've got some friends going up there in
a this weekend actually.
Oh, nice.
Cool.
Yeah.
Okay, great.
Great to hear from you, Thomas.
Hope to hear from you again.